trilogy if you see it back-to-back
Dunder Mifflin this is Pam Michael
what's wrong okay wait wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance okay way to say I thought you
said that you were hurt hey whoa Michael
okay Jim just say again really loudly
what happened you burned your foot on a
foreman mill I enjoy having breakfast in
bed I like waking up to the smell of
bacon sue me and since I don't have a
butler I have to do it myself so most
nights before I go to bed I will lay six
strips of bacon out on my George Foreman
grill then I go to sleep when I wake up
I plug in the grill I go back to sleep
again then I wake up to the smell of
crackling bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day today I got
up I stepped onto the grill and I
clamped down on my foot that's it I
don't see what's so hard to believe
about that time issue from the taco
powder just went down my throat I'm
stopping now why you're calling me no no
no no no no I'm calling okay I'm calling
because I'm an early bird and I'm a
night owl so I'm wise and I have worms
oh I got your sausage egg and cheese
biscuit
yummy yummy Thank You Ryan
what was the thing you needed me to come
in early for um the sausage egg and
cheese biscuit but thank you and why
don't you just take a couple hours
offices yours home alone risky business
take your pants off run around their
yacht I do I'm just gonna take a nap in
my car till work starts okay healthier
Dunder Mifflin this is Erin he's not
available right now
uh-huh yes sure I'll give you the
message when he gets up gets back
Michael I had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that Michael
had an entire chicken pot pie for lunch
and let me be more specific Michael ate
an entire family sized chicken pot pie
for lunch and then he promptly fell
asleep so we're all trying to be very
quiet so as to not wake him up before
5:00 p.m. which actually should be in
about
ten minutes okay are you sure you can
just watch what do you need from me
normally I don't condone leaving early
but I have an appointment with the horse
doctor how that horse became a doctor I
don't know no I'm kidding
he's just a regular doctor who shoots
your horse in the head when its leg is
broken like clockwork oh wow okay all
right let's all go home come on see you
all Damali a year they bring in a little
cart and they give away free pretzels
it's really not a big deal to some
people it is productivity is important
but how can I be productive if I have
this one little thing in my brain that I
could not get out and now one little
thing is a soft pretzel so I'm just
gonna have my soft pretzel I'll get to
work and I'll be super productive look
out for me oh hi please tell me you have
a sweet pretzel left we do we have 18
different toppings we have sweet glazed
cinnamon sugar chocolate white chocolate
fudge M&Ms caramel dipped mint chip
chocolate chip marshmallows nuts
toffee nuts coconut peanut butter
drizzle Oreo sprinkles cotton candy bits
in powdered sugar is there any way you
could do all the works you got it oh
right thank you wow it's a little early
for ice cream oh okay it's never too
early for ice cream Jim well we didn't
have any ice cream so this is mayonnaise
and black olives oh it's comfort food
all right god this old Donna thing is
gonna be okay you just stop beating
yourself up I know well I hope you're
right
we'll see what Dwight says why do we
have to see what Dwight says because I
have him investigating her I'm waiting
for a tech stop Michael no no no no no
undo that undo that that's too late do
you undo it I need to know otherwise
this thing is gonna spiral out of a monk
Michael okay I'm I'm going to talk
straight to you because I think you need
to hear it Michael this stop eating it
do you want to be happy look at you you
have a major self-destructive streak in
you hmm
and you you kind of Torpedo every
romantic relationship you're in that's
not
all right and I've known some wonderful
women Holly Carroll Jan alene Pauline my
mother
oh my mother Helene oh yeah yes yes yes
all of all of the greatest loves of my
life
you should stop this excited mm-hmm
everybody freaking out mm-hmm cool gonna
be fun
you're late thank you but I forgive you
because Dossett is my birthday what's up
hey oh happy birthday
ah thank you sir Michael's birthday it's
pretty fun to watch actually he gets
very excited and then he eats a lot of
cake and then he runs around the office
then he has a sugar crash in the
afternoon and then he falls asleep and
that's when we get our work done
somebody brought in Donuts for my
birthday happy birthday thanks who
brought him doughnuts
somebody got doughnuts from her birthday
happy birthday you didn't know was my
birthday I guess I forgot
well I guess I forgot to give you a
doughnut hmm
[Music]
stop it stop what is that it's for the
longest time by William Joel yeah
favorite song
yeah well I saw the radio my birthday
blows nobody miss on my birthday poster
apparently my mother is the only one who
cares enough to send me anything I
probably care more than she does
you're making it worse I bet Luke Perry
friends don't treat him like this okay
Wendy hot and juicy redhead I'll give
this a try Wendy
hello Wendy this is Kevin's friend
Michael this is Wendy
oh I'm sorry could you put her on please
this is a Wendy's restaurant okay um
could I just have a frosty and a baked
potato please I'll send somebody to pick
it up just have it ready that's ready
now well put it aside
[Music]
you